substantiate the
google's experiment that
in their setting in the benign noise
setting it is actually a good benchmark
in terms of tracking the fidelity so
i think the cross entropy
if it's a very important it's a useful
statistics to know
about uh it's a it's a useful statistic
to know about experiments in a
non-adversarial noisy setting
and and i think it's it's useful to know
uh i think uh as setting it as uh
you know a as a benchmark for
adversarial basically as a challenge for
classical algorithms that's that's
problematic because classical algorithms
can cheat
uh
and um
so so uh so in that sense uh i think
it's so it's a good i think it's a good
benign benchmark i'm not sure it's a
good adversarial benchmark
okay thanks uh thanks boy so let's maybe
um move on to the panel um so
let me just do a quick introduction so
we have we have a really uh
very
you know very good panel for this this
particular topic um
um so um
uh
bill fefferman um
who um
who was a was a postdoc at berkeley and
now he's on the faculty at uh at chicago
he's been studying you know this these
questions of uh the the uh random
quantum circuits and and advantage in
that but from a computational complexity
viewpoint
uh for a very long time uh sunwan chai
who is on who's a co-author on this
paper he he also coincidentally was
miller first talk at berkeley and he's
now in the faculty at mit and he's uh he
studied these questions again also quite
extensively from
uh from a physics theory viewpoint but
also you know statistical mechanics
viewpoint so so i think we can get very
different viewpoints and and search your
bike so uh uh you all know from previous
panel appearances so sergio is at google
and he's he's really i think he studied
again these these questions both from
the viewpoint of
the experimental effort at google but
also from from a theoretical viewpoint
so so i think we are going to
you know
we will get uh
really quite uh quite a
deep and broad uh view into into some of
these results so
uh maybe
what i'd like to do is uh you know
have the panelists you know take turns
at um giving their uh
their viewpoint and reactions and
summary of how how they view view these
results let me let me just um just say
that there's there was something that
brought as you said very briefly but me
i don't know if the game came across so
clearly so
um
i i think one of the one of the reasons
we found
in in the
in the
you know from uh from a computational
viewpoint uh you know random circuit
sampling
um
uh you know these these results on on
supremacy advantage quite compelling or
you know plausible was uh
was this um
aaronson chen and aaronson gunn uh
conjectures which which sort of are of
an asymptotic nature right they say look
um if if you were to
uh you know that that there's this this
when you when you're sampling the output
of a of a random quantum circuit
then um
um
then the output
the the strings that output tend to be
heavy they tend to be uh heavier than
average in terms of their probabilities
and then they have this specific
conjecture saying that
if you were to try to
recreate those you know try to generate
heavy outputs or you know there are
various statistical ways to to say this
but that that you
if you know you needed exponential if
you were trying to
recreate these
samples with this kind of characteristic
you needed exponential amount of
computing power
as a function of the of the total um
size of the circuit
and um and so what you're what you're
basically showing is asymptotically that
that uh that statement is not true and
so so maybe
you know just just highlighting that
aspect of what you showed and then maybe
we can go around and and see how
um i i just wanted to bring that up and
then
i'd really love to hear
what the panelists have to say generally
about about the talk and
and about all the points that you
brought up so in any order that you you
would like so would would one of you
like to step in first and
so i already talked for now so maybe
someone else can talk yeah yeah exactly
uh yeah so i'm happy i'm happy to start
maybe address some of the things that
umesh was saying because i have a
similar feeling um so so okay so uh so
first thanks to boss for giving a very
nice talk um it's very clear uh so so i
guess when i think about these this sort
of spoofing result for linear
cross-entropy i feel like there's sort
of two different perspectives and
they're related but i think uh still
sort of orthogonal in a way
and that's the first is sort of a
practical perspective where you can ask
you know uh for a fixed system size a
fixed circuit depth you know a fixed
fidelity you know does your classical
algorithm uh score better than the uh
the noisy experiment right and it seems
to me like uh the answer for the current
google experiment is is probably no like
they they seem to have outperformed your
algorithm but then you know somehow if
you play this game where you increase
the system size and you don't sort of
proportionally decrease the uh the gate
fidelity then then it seems like
eventually your your algorithm will will
win out right uh but and and so these
are of course interesting messages and
they help us with these non-theoretical
questions but i i think what i'd like to
talk about which is i think more related
to what umesh was saying is you know
what are the theoretical reasons we have
for believing that uh you know that
scoring on a benchmark like linear
cross-entropy is hard in the first place
right and i think the uh the main reason
we had as far as i could tell
theoretically um which is again
asymptotically so it's not not so
practical but still i think very
important was this conjecture by uh by
aaronson and gunn which said that you
know uh linear cross entropy uh is is
hard you know sufficiently is is hard to
score you know at a sufficiently high
level assuming a conjecture called uh x
squath is true right an x cloth i mean
we can we can formalize it but roughly
speaking uh you know for the purpose of
this panel what it's saying is that it
should be hard to uh to estimate uh you
know a fixed output probability of a
random circuit uh with a bias that's
slightly better uh like inverse
exponential and n better than the
trivial algorithm that just outputs one
over two to the n right and so if i i
maybe i'd like to start by uh by just
trying to to understand what exactly
you've shown it seems like you've fought
at least for some natural family of
circuits you know i if i understood your
your uh your slide you said this quickly
but it seemed like when the depth was
sublinear uh you know in in the system
size and you you've actually falsified
this x quad conjecture um so you know
assuming that's the case then what i
think what it's what it's saying is that
uh you know it might be hard to score
say one over poly in linear cross
entropy but we no longer have the sort
of theoretical justification we thought
we had uh namely you know uh before the
the sort of really formal evidence that
we had was was this connection between
you know uh linear scoring while and
linear cross entropy let's say one over
poly i understand of course the noisy
algorithm does not score one over poly
it squares something like two to the
minus d but let's just say we're we're
scoring really well i think this still
even if you know scoring one over poly
the only evidence we really had was this
iron sun and gun uh conjecture that this
x-squat conjecture and it seems like
you're you've falsified it so you know
we don't really have uh sort of a good
theoretical underpinning for this
conjecture um but but that's that's my
interpretation i'd love to hear more
about about what you have to say
yeah i mean i i i think maybe maybe uh i
don't know if i should answer or should
we should maybe continue uh but but
generally i think yeah the the
what we show is that for some natural uh
families of algorithms the it's really
about exponential in the depth as
opposed to exponentially in the size
and um yeah
and and when you think about can i just
sorry can i just confirm because there's
two problems we're talking about right
one is the uh the linear cross entropy
problem uh right which is about you know
outputting samples essentially that are
sufficiently heavy with respect to the
output distribution of the circuit and
and i think if i understood your your
talk what you were saying is that your
score on that on that particular problem
uh was something like inverse
exponential in in d
is that right and maybe there's like
some const there's some constant in the
exponent that we didn't say but it's
something like two to the minus constant
times d but then there's a separate okay
so then that doesn't for example
contradict the hardness of scoring one
over poly and linear cross entropy
uh but then there's a separate question
which is this aronson and gone
conjecture this exquoth uh conjecture
which is you know um how hard is it to
estimate um the output probability of
you know the fixed output probability
like the the probability we see the all
zeros outcome when we measure uh you
know to with to a bias that's inverse
exponential in n better than uh you know
the the trivial algorithm which always
outputs two to the minus n and if i if i
understood correctly there you were
actually able to uh to falsify that
conjecture for sublinear depth circuits
is that is that a correct understanding
yes and
now now i have to uh
remember the uh
numbers precisely maybe one of my
co-authors knows
can maybe maybe i can say a few words
yes
so
like
yeah technically speaking for the like
uh you know our result is that for the
depth that's it's not linear
we can actually get the string
distributions right that's correlated
with the ideal output
and then in some sense this result is
not terribly surprising
from point of view of say physics okay
to do that
let's consider like not the qubit with
the spins you start from all spins like
polarized down and zero
and then let's make a mean field
approximation i'm going to study how
these spins will evolve under this
random unitary circuit
but i'm not going to simulate the full
quantum dynamics but for example i'm
only interested in say one particular
speed in the middle is more likely to be
up or more likely to be down
and one best one way to do that is okay
you know we forget about simulating
entire you know circuits but calculate
the expectation value of say a z
operator of that particular spin at the
output spin of the output you know of
the channel
and then just try to estimate by best by
starting from mean field approximations
and then adding the perturbations
gradually i'm just talking about the
five minus path integral formulating
and the operator basis right and what it
means is that you know if the depth is
not as large like to not
it's definitely sufficiently you know
you know short compared to the system
size
actually this polarization information
can be estimated by including all the
paths like usually simple paths not
involving entire many body you know the
interference which is reasonable if
depth is not crazy deep
so in this regime we can estimate these
correlated b strings by just figuring
out the polarization of the output
so it's okay so there was this
conventional wisdom i think when it came
to uh x cloth that i think was advocated
by a number of papers which was that
sort of the best thing you can do to
estimate the fixed you know the output
probability of a fixed uh outcome of a
random circuit is to is to essentially
take a a feynman path integral which had
you know in the standard basis which had
like two to the nd terms or something
like exponential in the size terms and
sort of sub sample and i think the idea
was somehow that you know because it was
a random circuit all of the paths should
have about equal weight and and so on
and you know because that was the best
you can do uh this sort of motivated the
quad conjecture and it seems like that
you're you're sort of saying explicitly
that this is not this is not the case
for some interesting regime of
parameters uh you know you can do better
than than that is that is that right
yeah but let me make a modification in
two aspects okay first of all
the you know if you write down xcb
that's actually closely related to the
formulation of quas however there we are
not talking about the single
uh single bit strings but actually the
average over all the strings will be
summed over all these strings right so
here the problem is a little more
relaxed because we are not you know you
are not given a particular strength and
estimate the probability of that strings
but we are okay to get whatever the
correlated strings distributions output
so then we do you know relaxes uh you
know program a little bit uh and
actually what was the second part um
yeah
um
i think maybe maybe even like for new uh
for
say suppose you you have like a really
really shallow circuit like a constant
depth circuit
then and suppose these were like high
random gates
then even the marginals are probably not
going to be perfectly a half half right
so so just look at the say uh just look
at the first five uh
the first five outputs of the ignore
everything else and just based on this
marginal you could get some estimate
uh you might be able to get some
estimate of the probability of that
string which would be non non-trivial
so i mean maybe that would give all the
intuition where you don't necessarily
have to
you you can have shortcuts if you're
just trying to get something that is
correlated right you don't need you you
don't need to know exactly the
the probability distribution but you
want to get some estimate that is
correlated with the distribution that
say when it's up it's more likely to be
up and if it's down it's more likely to
be down
and when you don't know you just say i
don't know
yeah actually let me add to that point
because like this is this is something
that i found very interesting um so
naively will say all path will have this
you know same probability which is not
true if you assume unitary is 30 from
the higher random because how random
doesn't always maximize uh you know the
weight
or like maximally mixes the rate but
sometimes you don't behave with z
rotations so on average actually there's
a certain correlation we can learn from
it so initially we were leveraging those
approaches
and then actually like thanks to sergio
actually we learned from
uh sergio actually the google circuit
actually is more it's a better design
it's almost near optimum design so that
actually circuit makes sure that all the
b string paths uh have the equal
amplitude so that's actually extremely
difficult situation to simulate and then
we realized maybe we don't do the path
integral in the original state basis but
in the poly operator basis
and there the small weight operators has
a higher
you know amplitude in the path integral
therefore the simulation is not entirely
exponentially you know distributed
sorry can i can i just ask a very quick
question and then i i'd love for sergio
to
chime in as well because you haven't had
a chance but
just to follow up very quickly soon one
um
to what you were saying about depth so
um shallow circuits
so
what if you what if you were to restrict
attention to circuits where where you
have n qubits and depth n
you know so where where the where the
depth is roughly the same as the number
of qubits then
does your result actually say something
uh non-trivial there with respect to
aarons and gun or is that where it sort
of stops saying something
[Music]
uh
it's tricky that first of all like our
scaling behavior that only depends on
the depth will still be the truth
however now now the game is okay we have
a you know decaying our over the
correlation with dk as a function of
depth but now depth itself is a system
size therefore the amount of correlation
will be exponentially small and then
each order like dimension of the hilbert
space
all right so so here um when the depth
is equal to the number of qubits
so are you thinking of the system size
as number of qubits or the number of
gates so the number of gates would now
be
sorry
yeah yeah i would meant to say the
number of cubits if the if the depth is
equal to the number of qubits
our performance or the correlation
decays as a function of depth
but that's already you know exponential
in the number of tributes
and you can match it with the magic with
the dimension so now it's questionable
whether our result is useful or not
because you know we yes we say that we
can extract the correlations you know
amount which is order inverse triple
space dimension and is it is it useful
like i probably i'll say no you know
colloquially internally we say this is
garbage regime you know you get the
correlations but you know it's just
zero correlation in practice right so so
yes that's right so i mean so in some
sense there's a fine tuning required and
then we need to actually put in the
values to get the you know results that
within a reasonable scaling regime at
the same time make sense and not in the
garbage machine yeah okay great thanks
so sergio you've been very patient so
can you
uh do you want to
to build
sure yeah uh
so yeah of course i you know i think all
these um approaches are interesting and
to the question if
xcv is a good measure in an adversarial
setting or linear xcp i agree it is not
a good measure especially
if you don't have large steps i you know
i agree with with that uh
nevertheless the way
i see random circuit sampling which you
know doesn't have to be the way
everybody sees it but you know the way i
see it
is it's a sampling problem right so then
the the problem itself is to sample from
a distribution
with good fidelity that's the way i
think about it so then of course the
problem is what does it mean to be you
know to have good fidelity
um
and it's complicated uh but but we have
these
xcd measures which are estimators of
fidelity and linear xv is one of them we
also have logarithmic xcv for instance
and then we make sure in in our
experiment that we check
that linear xcv and logarithmic xcv
match within a statistical error which
doesn't happen for low enough depth
actually uh
in our experiment we had enough depth
that it works so what that means and you
can do other things you need to check
that you have enough entropy which there
are ways to check that as well
meaning you know you're not just
producing one bit of string all the time
or or a lot of beta strings with low
statistical distance
so i think you know eventually when you
have large enough fidelity and you can
run circles with large enough depth all
these things that doesn't really matter
anymore because just getting any bias on
the probability becomes exponentially
hard in depth
uh but in the regime where we are now
where you know unfortunately we have
fairly nice noisy gates and we can go
only to certain depths then i think all
these other tests are as important so in
particular you know checking that you
have
good linear depth and and and sorry that
the lower rhythmic xcv and the linear
xcv coincide and i think in the in the
method that they use in in this paper
uh if you check the logarithmic cv it
will not coincide with the linear xcv
[Music]
i see so so sorry are you are you are
you suggesting that um
that lineage cb for you you know
can be used as a proxy for logarithmic
xcv which is which is really what you
wanted to do no
no sorry no what we really want is good
fidelity sure sure
and
you know when things go well
linear xcv is a good proxy of fidelity
and actually one thing that is nice
about this paper it gives more clarity
to what it means things go well
right like like you can actually
we have a better understanding now of
you know roughly speaking is related to
being in the port of thomas regimes and
whatnot but some of the techniques in
this paper
the popular population dynamics
techniques actually allows you to which
some people in our group igor and kostya
were looking into as well allows you to
quantify it better what it means to be
on the port of thomas regime and and
allows you to say with more precision
when you can try you know when you
contrast
uh linear xps as a proxy of fidelity
uh but
again the point here for me is to sample
with good fidelity linear xcv is an
estimator of fidelity when things go
well and they can go wrong lower ethnic
xcv is another estimator of fidelity and
there are more
infinitely more actually but anyway just
as a
for us it it looks like lower in nick
xcv and linear xv are both good measures
and then we check that they both
coincide
right so when you try to spoof the
sampling that's something if you are
interested in spoofing the sampling
which is not the approach that boss is
taking i guess the birth of the boss is
taking is let's just prove you know
linear xcv but if you take it as a
sampling problem which is my point of
view
then you try to you know ideally you
will try to
uh
make sure that you pass all the possible
tests
for something
correctly early so the ones that have
you know good sample efficiency and in
particular checking that linear xp and
logarithmic actually coincide
so so do you think maybe you conjecture
that maybe um logarithmic xcv is harder
to spoof than linear xcv it's harder to
spoof for this particular method yes i
where we for example
if you were to go back to
and soon
would you would you say that your
techniques may would well you know is it
is it clear to you when you look at your
techniques that um they're really
tailored to linear xcp right and would
they yeah it's definitely tailored but i
would just say i think the way i would
phrase uh sergio's a claim
or a view is the following so i uh
i said i kind of defined the problem
with respect to a benchmark
i said the benchmark should be
statistically efficient and
such is basically saying
let's not
have this restriction
or let's let's look at the two
probability distances like for the
probability distances like normal human
beings look at
and er and almost any probability
distance measure so whether it's
fidelity which i think in the context of
classical feeling would be the
bhattachar constant or a total variation
okay divergence all of those type of
probability distances
are going to be
to require exponential number of samples
but maybe that's okay we still can do
the same type of approach which
basically we can look at small
cases uh
get a
and get evidence that a certain
proxies are a good benchmark for this
and then uh
and and and then and then extend so
so i think basically the
the the the main uh i guess
problem with uh
maybe the main problem in some sense
with the uh
with using a a distance measure that is
that you cannot use a
polynomial number of samples to check
is that say uh you know if
it makes it a little bit harder in some
sense yeah potentially like a classical
algorithm like for example you know i i
cannot build in my basement like say say
google came up and come up with a black
box
and uh
and and now i
cannot build in my basement and say here
is a box and it also samples from the
same probability distribution because
because you need like two to the 50
samples from these probabilities the
vision to evaluate something like uh
fidelity uh so
which maybe it's fine like i mean this
is also a view maybe i'm
unreasonably restricted to a
polynomial number of samples to sample
efficiency
and we can look at them at benchmarks
that don't require by sample efficiency
but um i think we should be clear that
that's what we're doing
so sorry uh yeah no that's that's very
interesting but going back to what what
sergio said uh doesn't doesn't it create
a give you a very interesting open
question you know so suppose you wanted
to suppose somebody some came to you and
said look can you now recreate your
results for for log xcb because you know
in some sense
the regime that google was using was one
where linear and and log xcb coincided
but but maybe you know we can sort of
say well maybe that was the that was you
know that was the original uh
measure they had in mind log xcb for a
very long time and then eventually at
the last minute you know they sort of
said well it actually works also with
linear xcb and that's the
you know that's where the irons and gun
conjecture was
there is
there is something very different okay
so log xcb it's basically a cradle
divergence right this is what we're
talking about
so kale divergence
you think about it like suppose you have
uh
you know the uniform distribution
and you have a a pseudorandom
distribution that has a
far far far smaller support right
so it's very very different in kl
distance
so so this is basically it shows that
you cannot evaluate it using a
polynomial number of samples
you basically in in so pseudo might not
have been even the right thing like say
sing an actual random with a
but over say two to the square root and
entries so it's very dis different in
kl
but it would take you more than a a
polynomial number of samples to know the
difference
so basically this log divergence is not
a metric that is statistically efficient
so
yeah i don't know i haven't thought
about it but i would just say that like
this is just a different ballgame like
it's a different type of benchmark and
you should be kind of clear uh if
if that's the benchmark because i think
it's it's worthwhile to try to think
about what what is precisely the
benchmark that we set forward and what
are the properties of this benchmark so
it's one thing to give up on
computational efficiency
i think it's an it's another thing to
even give up on sample efficiency uh it
doesn't mean that it's meaningless it's
still meaningful and still interesting
but it's we should be aware that we are
doing it and i think if the difference
between linear and log that's the
difference
logarithmic actually sample efficient
right
logarithmic activity is it is sample
efficiency
okay so what's
the kl divergence but you don't evaluate
the term that corresponds to entropy of
the sampling that you're performing so
you only first a cross term not the
second term therefore you do not have to
estimate the entropy of the sampling
distribution that's why i'm saying you
have to you know both check these
estimators of fidelity and then you need
to have an additional check of entropy
because yeah but yeah right but i would
like to add to what the guaz is saying
in the following right i mean no matter
whether it's a linear version of xav or
the logarithmic version of xab at the
end of the day the whole idea is we
compare the correlations between the
sampling distribution we have
and the original probability
distributions right so that's the idea
but we need to ask ourselves whether
that's enough to certify the sampling
task
because for example as you know as you
know some of us know
suppose we sample one particular b
strings again and again
and then this particular b strings is
associated with the you know heavy
output like the probability to obtain
that b string is
above average for example
but of course we don't we know it's we
are not doing the sampling right however
if you evaluate if you consider the
correlations between the sampling
distributions and the original
distribution it is
it's correlated in a non-trivial way
right
so what you need that's right you check
correlations
and
and in that sense lowering meat xv tends
to behave better than linear cv because
linear exhibit is sort of very sensitive
to very high probability bit strings
logarithmic xcv sort of smoother and you
need to
estimate entropy
which you can do
i mean there are probably other ways to
do it but one way we know how to do is
to make sure that you don't have many
meter strings which are
too close and hamming distance to each
other
and you can do this efficiently for not
very large having distance
i mean yeah
but what is saying the second part you
know showing that the distribution has
its own entropy very large
is actually fundamentally difficult
because we want to verify that the
entropy associated with it is scaling
with the you know the number of qubits
um and then inevitably actually you know
first is us to sample uh number of
sample scales exponentially with the
number of qubits so that's that's why
you know that statistics will be
statistically not as efficient
um yeah i mean i i think it's also like
the case that uh also in cryptography we
kind of once you start going into this
cat and mouse type of thing where you
fix the benchmark etcetera it seems like
it could be never ending so in some
sense maybe you would say
if we don't have a clean
statistically efficient benchmark maybe
we do maybe we don't and we just simply
say right now the benchmark is not
statistically efficient and right now we
are okay with that and maybe that's okay
also
so so the scientific claim is that
this is a device which uh samples from a
certain probability distribution
and
no classical device of similar uh
of anything related to it in resources
could sample from a probability
distribution that is uh
close to it in say total variation or
yeah that's that's a fine scientific
claim we just need to be clear that this
is the claim we are making
i have a question then like i think in
our paper we try to be clear about that
if you actually read it
that you know we're talking about a
sampling problem and i agree with you
then the problem is you know how do you
check it and and there is no jacket so
then we propose
you know several methods
we propose these estimators of fidelity
we check that they coincide and then in
addition you have to you know make sure
that you have good entropy uh which we
know how to do up to certain but by
looking for not too many collisions
incoming distance and it works up to
certain hamming distances i think it was
like exponential in a human distance so
that won the scale forever i guess yeah
and i wonder
i i will actually i have a question for
all of you
so suppose we give up about you know
statistical efficiency in other words in
order to show that our device is doing
the right thing
you know i need to sample exponentially
many times and that of course physically
takes exponentially long time
and can we does it actually constitute
you know quantum advantage in a sense
that while we are sampling maybe we do
the brute force calculations for a very
long time
such a way that by the time we are done
with the exponential many segments we
obtain the probability distributions
from the classical computation using
exponentially large amount of resources
and now sampling is immediate because we
have all like probability distribution
like full probability distribution so i
think
we cannot just say we ditch out
statistical efficiency because
then that actually changes the
complexity from the quantum side
so maybe like we need to actually keep
one of them um so that we can we can
keep the separation between quantity
classroom actually meant to be a
question so what do you why do you think
about this i mean i i think i agree with
you and that's why we propose
you know these two things right like the
estimators of fidelity linear
logarithmic in particular and making
sure that they coincide and in addition
um you know you need to check the
entropy somehow
and
you know it is an upper problem
uh
if that's good enough maybe it's not but
but you know they agree with you that
it's important to actually propose
some you know sample efficient
method
ideally computationally efficient too
but
we don't know how to do that so we gave
up on that
yeah
great well um
thank you this was a fantastic
discussion um let's see um
uh we are running uh it's it's towards
the end of our time but um
maybe maybe we can take
just a few minutes for
both um
any comments from from any of the uh any
of the audience as well as um
maybe
you know if there's a last comment
anybody wants to give on the panel uh
you haven't heard a lot from bill i
don't know if you have more to say
yeah i mean i'm happy to say a lot of
things i i think uh i think for so i i
completely agree with everyone i think
it's really important that we have uh
statistical efficiency i think you know
number of uh samples is uh is efficient
i think you know would be better if we
also had computational efficiency
but i guess i i want to be clear that it
sounds like um what sergio is saying is
not necessarily that we need uh you know
to to look at new uh you know tests that
are not sample efficient but rather that
we need to look at a whole bunch of
tests it would be better if they were
all sample efficient we need to sort of
consider all of these you know including
the original sort of logarithmic cross
entropy uh and the linear cross entropy
and then see if we can we can sort of
use those as a proxy for uh you know for
for fidelity and it sounds like you
would be more happy if if all of these
uh were sample efficient um
is that is that is that right uh sergio
sorry i don't think we can hear you
yes and you need to check for entropy in
edition and you know
and unfortunately that's maybe not so uh
we
a method to check for at least not you
don't have high collisions in coming
distance
and
unfortunately
now we haven't published that yet
actually
but yeah um there is a there is you know
that's that's something you can do
checking that you don't have too many
high collisions in coming distance so
that you know the beta strings are
uh you can't like how many heated
strings you have having distance five
for any video streams or have listed
three or how many seven
and you know you compare with what you
will expect and you see that you don't
have too many you know the bt streams
are not clustered
in a small humming distance which is i
think exponentially in having distance
but for these kind of experiments at
least we can do it will break down
eventually
i'll have to go back and see the details
again
let me suggest one more thing actually
which is that you know a lot of the uh
the reason for these these sort of um uh
you know these unfortunate results about
how these tests are not sampled
efficient comes from uh this sort of
very stringent uh you know setting that
we're in which we're really we really
don't want to be trusting the black box
at all right uh you know that's where we
start to get these lower bounds on uh
query on query complexity for testing uh
you know
total variation distance and so on and
and of course we don't you know
my attitude is that quantum supremacy is
already a pretty paranoid goal so we
certainly don't want to make you know
too many assumptions or else we may as
well just assume you know this this that
quantum mechanics works and get on with
our life but but i'm wondering
especially from sergio whether there's
some sort of in between where maybe by
making a little bit more assumption
about the noise uh you know that it's
not totally adversarial if that could
sort of help us um with this sample
efficiency uh you know
you know increase the sample efficiency
of some of these tests
it's already on boss and and soon on
paper that you know if you assume the
noise is independent in every gate
that's one of the nice results in the
paper
then things are
yeah what they expect so the answer is
actually yes there are some some
settings but maybe we're not quite happy
with with these sorts of uh that that's
wrong of an assumption i mean a
classical algorithm doesn't need to
evade you know this particular
constraint right yeah
so actually uh on a related note i i
guess i it isn't it worth discussing
or at least bringing up this issue that
um
uh xcb can be used uh you know it's
being used for benchmarking and so
uh
you know
maybe maybe it's worth you know sort of
correlating that with that subject of
the what what you said very very briefly
yeah sorry
yeah so like
that's very good point that's what i
wanted to emphasize here so we use a
term benchmark but i realize that it's
being used in a different way among
physicists or scientists versus a
computer scientist
in the physics side we are just checking
whether device is working in a way that
we expect it to work and then we put the
reasonable assumptions that's believable
but
from quantum experience purposes or
quantum advantage purposes we need to be
adversarial you know we need to put the
bound we need to you know consider all
possible spring method and then we have
a benchmarking for a certain task but
not the benchmarking for a quantum
device
and then by working on this xcp the
sharp distinction between these two role
is something that i realized
so i fully trust like a rules experiment
and then you know it's really remarkable
right and i i it's very believable that
errors will be maybe maybe local and
maybe like uncorrelated and very weak
so i actually trust that i mean and also
our analysis indicates that the fidelity
they have achieved is actually very
close to what they have already claimed
the problem is like quantum advantage
task is i ask of a different aspect you
know like is this task the benchmark for
the task against all the spoofing
algorithm you know can be certified by
xdb so so this adversarial setting is
what we are talking about and i would
like to make two comments one is the
first aspect is benchmarking quantum
divide is a brilliant idea and indeed
actually my colleague and i have worked
on how to generalize this approach so
they work for the analog quantum
simulators more broad classes that's not
running random energy circuit
the second command is
the like adversarial setting i'm not
sure whether we have to delegate you
know we have to force for example google
to come up with a better benchmark like
in some sense this is this should be i
think a community effort you know google
already you know make all the
measurement data and then samples and
the choice of gate like you know very
transparent and publicly available and
then maybe we should as a community
develop a new computational benchmark um
by ourselves and they try whether the
google sample uh you know it passes this
test or not
so like i wanted to emphasize that we
shouldn't actually try to like move into
the situation where you know okay you
should try to prove that you have done a
good job maybe as a community you should
come up with a better benchmark and then
you know help like google start to find
their sampling task
great um
um
maybe shall we let that be the last word
and
uh thank you all thanks for us for
her
great talk and
thank you to all the panelists and um
see you all next week garnet chan is
going to talk about the possibility of
quantum advantage in quantum chemistries
see you then
thank you
thanks thank you thank you
you